à shannon près de la base de valcartier
la déclaration du chef d'état-major fait
sursauter il est allé trop loin pour cet
ancien réserviste charlie juste protéger
j'avais peur du saut je suis un anglais
c'est ça non
je comprends l'anglais je comprends pas
virer le nom en langue que vous voulez
c'est aux quinze ans ça aucune chance de
dire qu'une personne et est
biologiquement prédestiné à une
agression non une déclaration dégradant
juste le militaire de carrière salle
aucun sens et c'est un mois je croise
des assassins saint-amand à terre
gratuit yatuu les études là dessus je
pense la peau des propos pour lesquels
des militaires tiennent test distancié
malgré les excuses du grand patron de
l'armée les papiers on n'est pas plus pu
violer les eaux rejetées
on est au mieux les papilles cette
déclaration survient au moment où la
lieutenant général christine whitecross
commandant de l'équipe d'intervention
stratégique des forces armées
canadiennes sur les conduites sexuelles
fait une tournée à travers les bases
militaires pour faire connaître aux
hommes du rang et aux officiers le plan
d'action de la remit ça veut dire que la
culture dans l'armée et s y fait c'est
la grande crainte du conseil du statut
de la femme que ce discours soit plus
répandu qu'on ne le croit dans les
forces canadiennes
c'est grave qu'un haut gradé 10 parce
que ça reprend toutes les fausses
croyances tous les stéréotypes qu'on
tente depuis des années de défaire parce
que non il n'y a aucune programmation
biologique qui fait que les hommes
pourraient être davantage tentés de
harceler sexuellement les femmes que l'
inverse je pense que ça juste sorti de
sa bouche jusqu'à mme sophie gardon on
est humaine puis ya passé comme sotchi
puis
dans sa position ben y'a pas dit les
bonbons des militaires qui serrent les
rangs comme ils le peuvent
ici qu'additionner radio-canada chaman
et l'ex caporal stéphane hermant a elle
aussi réagi
elle écrit même si le général s'est
excusé c'est trop tard maintenant nous
connaissons son opinion de connaissons
ce qu'il pense
nous savons qu'ils adhèrent la culture
du viol stéphanie raymond je le rappelle
avait été mise à la porte de l'armée
après avoir porté des accusations
d'agressions sexuelles contre son
supérieur
elle a finalement obtenu des excuses des
forces canadiennes